all I've ever wanted to do is make
people feel good and laugh and there is
no greater feeling than when someone
tells me that I've made their day better
with my show Ellen DeGeneres took home
the Carol Burnett award at the 2020
Golden Globes on Sunday making her the
second person ever to receive the high
honor
aside from Carol Burnett herself Ellen
DeGeneres is getting the Carol Burnett
award what does that mean to you she's a
friend she's a buddy now we're breaking
down the five best moments from her
acceptance speech starting with this
people just go on and on and on and on
and on and on on on and you're like I'm
not gonna do that I'm gonna be quick
although I don't have to because it's a
special award and they don't they don't
play me off yep she brought the laughs
poking fun at those infamously long
accepted speeches I'm gonna keep it
quick I was born in New Orleans in 1958
Ellen got a standing ovation from the
crowd and laid a big old smooch on her
wife Portia de Rossi then there was this
I am an open book and I couldn't have
done it without my husband mark you are
my rock no one seemed to love the joke
more than Portia the point is you all
know me Ellen also gave a special
shout-out to Carol who was in the
audience we counted on her to make us
feel good and she delivered every single
week she never let us down then Ellen
gave us all the fields noting that the
greatest reward for her was people
telling her she inspired them to make
people laugh to be kind and to help
others in need that is the power of
television and I'm so so grateful to be
a part of it
ét caught up with Ellen backstage after
she accepted the award what does it mean
to get the carol burnett award to be the
first person to get it out of all the
people on the planet what does it mean
to you I mean
obviously would have meant more to me to
get it before Carol first yeah it's it's
a it's a lot it's it's really she's
she's you know somebody that I was you
know crazy about growing up and so to
have my name next to her name in any
form is amazing she said you guys had
dinner just the other night yeah yeah
yeah so you hang with Carol did you I do
know Carol we're we're pals yes and the
feeling is mutual here's what Carol told
et about Ellen before the show when you
look at the landscape of these funny
ladies who are now following in your
footsteps alright do you do you feel
pride and that you really paved the way
for so many of these women that's very
nice of you but you know what I say if
I'd never been born they'd be doing what
they're doing I'm just happy to be here
to support Ellen I'm sure she loves it
and in support it will be at the same
table so we'll be having a good chin wag
and we'll be watching you you know that
we'll be watching
[Music]